Russia's paramilitary proxy group, Varna,
have begun to try and influence
one of the parties.
They we believe from the evidence
that we've seen a recent
plying have been resupplying
the Rapid Support
Force paramilitary group.
Take a look at this
the Sudanese and the Libyan army
celebrated a successful joint
operation Wednesday,
April 19th,
near the remote
desert border between Libya and Sudan.
Having captured
the Scheffer, that garrison
belonging to the rival
Sudanese paramilitary
rapid support forces, the RCAF.
But why is this garrison important,
given how far it is
from the existential fight
in Sudan's capital, Khartoum?
Because CNN can reveal
that the fight in Khartoum
is being influenced by what was happening
at that garrison.
A Russian resupply campaign
backed by a key regional player aimed
at turning the tide
in Sudan's war in favor of the RAAF,
who have been a key
recipient of Russian training
and military aid.
In collaboration
with All Eyes on Wagner, a research group
focusing on Russian proxy Wagner.
CNN investigated the group's
current presence in Libya.
You can see here on April 16th.
One day after the fighting
began in Khartoum, a Russian Aleutian.
76 transport
plane at the edge of a base in Libya
previously identified
by American intelligence
as a Virginia base.
Three days later,
this same plane is spotted by
flight tracker aviation expert Gudgeon
coming back from the Russian airbase
in Latakia, Syria,
before returning to the Libyan airbase
in Haditha.
Images of that
same plane began
circulating online April 17th.
Heading in the direction of Sudan.
Sudanese and regional sources
tell CNN that weaponry
was airdropped to the RAAF
within that timeframe.
April 15th to April 18th
to the Chevrolet Garrison
during a period of fierce fighting,
boosting the ISF, the Alpha Adim
and algebra bases
where the Volga planes
departed from in Libya
under the control of Field
Marshal Khalifa Haftar,
who commands territory
in the east of Libya.
Haftar
and the commander of the rapid support
forces, Mohamed Hamdan Dagalo, a.k.a.
committee, have in common
strategic alliances, one with Valbuena,
who Haftar is hosting in his territory
in Libya,
and whom
a previous CNN investigation
exposed as working with Hemmati
to extract Sudanese gold.
A second
with the United Arab
Emirates, who tapped him ready
to send forces to the conflict in Yemen
and backed Haftar
in the fighting in Libya.
What does it
all mean
for the ongoing
misery and conflict in Sudan?
It means that both a regional Libyan
General Haftar
and a global player
Russia are putting their thumbs
on the scale,
which raises the stakes for the region,
for the global balance of power,
and for the people of Sudan.
Caught in the crossfire,
we reached out to both Haftar and Wagner
and didn't receive a response
to our requests for comment
and ourselves.
Spokesperson denied
that they were currently receiving
support from Libya or Russia,
although they had previously denied
when our investigation
exposed their relationship with Wagner
that there was a relationship.
So at least this time
they've admitted that they had
a previous relationship.
For what that's worth, Jake.